[Música]
son las 8 y 29 de la noche en Bogotá
quito y lima y nosotros continuamos en
directo América edición nocturna
seguimos comentandoles los principales
hechos del día Les agradecemos su
sintonía y vamos con los titulares de
esta jornada
ya son más de 230 los muertos y
alrededor de 850 los heridos tras el
choque de tres trenes en el estado de
dicha en India se trata del peor
accidente ferroviario en el país durante
la última década y las cifras pueden
aumentar Pues continúan los trabajos de
rescate en la zona
como una gran noticia para el pueblo
estadounidense así calificó el
presidente Joe biden la aprobación en el
congreso del proyecto de ley que
suspende el techo de la deuda en el país
el mandatario agradeció a los líderes
del Congreso que según el actuaron
responsablemente vayan sancionará a la
normativa este sábado Tenemos reporte
Panamá lanzó la llamada operación chocó
que comprende desplegar 1200 agentes en
la zona del Darién fronteriza con
Colombia para enfrentar a las bandas
criminales que afectan a migrantes por
la zona han cruzado más de 166.000
migrantes en situación irregular en lo
que va de 2023
[Aplausos]
[Música]
vamos a comenzar en India donde ya son
más de 230 las personas que han perdido
la vida en un accidente ferroviario en
el sureste del país dos trenes que
llevaban pasajeros a bordo se
descarrilaron y chocaron contra un tren
de carga Que estaba estacionado en las
vías los equipos de rescate continúan en
el lugar para intentar salvar a decenas
de pasajeros que quedaron atrapados en
el accidente de igual manera los más de
800 heridos han sido trasladados a
hospitales locales el informe es de Max
Pérez Gallardo
tragedia en la India en el estado de
odisha al este del territorio indio dos
trenes de pasajeros se descarrilaron en
la noche el viernes lo que provocó una
colisión frontal con un tren de carga
las autoridades locales reportan decenas
de fallecidos y cientos de heridos los
sobrevivientes narran el horror del
accidente
cuando salí del vagón del tren vi que
alguien había perdido la mano alguien
había perdido la pierna
mientras que la cara de alguien estaba
distorsionada luego salí de allí y desde
entonces he estado sentado aquí
los equipos de rescate siguen las
labores para sacar a múltiples personas
que han quedado atrapadas entre vigas y
humo el Primer Ministro narendamody
reaccionó al siniestro en su cuenta de
Twitter expresando sus condolencias a
las víctimas y remarcando que se está
prestando toda la ayuda posible a Los
afectados reportes indican que más de
500 rescatistas se encuentran en el
lugar y la policía local ya se encuentra
haciendo labores de coordinación entre
distintas instancias relacionadas al
incidente
el accidente ferroviario que ha tenido
lugar en balasor es muy desafortunado la
policía ferroviaria está haciendo todos
los preparativos para coordinar a los
ferrocarriles y a la administración
proporcionaremos toda la ayuda necesaria
a las familias de los heridos cuando se
pongan en contacto con nosotros
el ministro de ferrocarriles de la India
anunció que el gobierno otorgara
compensaciones económicas a las familias
de las víctimas en lo que podría ser uno
de los peores accidentes en la historia
moderna de la India
cambiamos de tema y actualizamos la
información de la guerra en Ucrania
porque este viernes se registraron
nuevos ataques alrededor de kiev la
capital del país pero también en la
localidad rusa de belgorot cerca de la
frontera entre ambas naciones donde dos
mujeres murieron Rusia y combatientes
pero ucranianos se culparon mutuamente
por la muerte de civiles ampliamos en el
informe
estos residentes fueron evacuados de
vélgorot después de que la región rusa
fuera atacada
nos dieron dos horas para marcharnos y
no nos llevamos nada ni documentos ni
nada vimos la explosión Cuando llegamos
una de las ciudades de situada cerca de
la frontera con Ucrania fue golpeada el
jueves dos personas murieron Rusia culpó
a los kumbayentes procranianos
fragmentos de los proyectiles alcanzaron
carros que pasaban dos mujeres viajaban
en uno de ellos murieron de sus heridas
en el acto por su parte los combatientes
rusos que apoyan a Ucrania la legión de
la libertad de Rusia culparon a Rusia de
los bombardeos diciendo que sus fuerzas
confundieron a civiles con combatientes
en Ucrania continuaron los ataques
aéreos Incluso en kiev y sus alrededores
Rusia lanzado unas 20 oleadas de ataques
contra la capital desde principios de
mayo
durante la noche las fuerzas
aeroespaciales de Rusia han llevado a
cabo múltiples ataques con armas de
largo alcance contra los sistemas de
defensa antiaérea enemigos que cubren
instalaciones clave de infraestructuras
militares críticas en Ucrania todos los
objetivos asignados fueron alcanzados
estos sistemas aérea han ayudado a
revelar los ataques rusos Aunque incluso
cuando detienen los cohetes sus restos
pueden causar muerte y destrucción el
jueves mataron a tres personas en kiev
vamos a Estados Unidos porque el
presidente dio su balance en un mensaje
televisado Luego de que en la noche del
jueves el senado aprobara la ley sobre
el techo de la deuda esto trazar las
negociaciones entre demócratas y
republicanos previamente Cristóbal
Vázquez corresponsal de France 24 en la
capital estadounidense nos contó lo más
destacado del mensaje de vaivén
yo voy del resaltó que mi demócratas ni
republicanos en este acuerdo tuvieron
todo lo que querían pero que se obtuvo
lo que los estadounidenses necesitaban Y
en este sentido es de Resaltar que se
aunque se limite el gasto público en los
próximos dos años se levanta este techo
de la deuda para que Estados Unidos
pueda cumplir con sus obligaciones
financieras se suspende este límite en
el techo de la deuda y así Estados
Unidos no entra en default como lo
hubiera entrado a partir de el lunes
cinco de junio como lo había resaltado
la secretaria del tesoro Janeth jelen es
de Resaltar también en este discurso que
el presidente biden dijo que a él le
habían dicho cuando había empezado acá
en la casa blanca que era imposible
trabajar con los republicanos de forma
bipartidista pero que precisamente
después de estas semanas de arduas
negociaciones Pues él contradijo esto
que le decían a él llegar a la casa
blanca que era imposible trabajar de
forma conjunta y fue precisamente este
acuerdo bipartidista estas negociaciones
y este trabajo de cabildeo en el
congreso el que precisamente le permite
hoy al presidente haber dado este
discurso donde le dice al país que se
evitó un colapso financiero se evitó que
Estados Unidos pues eh hubiera entrado y
las calificadoras de riesgo hubieran
bajado la calificación de Estados Unidos
que hubiera entre otras efectos
económicos negativos hubiera encarecido
el acceso a crédito de Estados Unidos y
estuviera tenido obviamente un efecto
dominó en las finanzas de los
estadounidenses hay que Resaltar también
que pues biden quiere seguir trabajando
de forma conjunta precisamente para
seguir avanzando en el rumbo económico
de Estados Unidos
las autoridades panameñas lanzaron un
operativo para combatir a los grupos
criminales que atacan a migrantes en la
selva del Darién la zona que conecta a
Colombia con su vecino del Norte la
denominada operación chocó contará con
el despliegue de 1200 agentes en el
darían para frenar la presencia de
bandas armadas internacionales Max Pérez
Gallardo nos amplía
Panamá fortifica el tapón del Darién
1200 tropas serán desplegadas en la
selva del Darién por el gobierno
panameño con el objetivo de combatir la
presencia de grupos criminales que
violentan a los migrantes que transitan
por la frontera natural del país con
Colombia la operación chocó el resultado
de un esfuerzo conjunto del servicio
Nacional de Migración y el servicio
nacional de fronteras que tiene como
objetivo principal diezmar las
operaciones ilegales
todo el entramado del tráfico de
migrantes en este momento lo está
maniobrando articulando y desarrollando
específicamente en nuestros informes de
inteligencia la organización
narcoterrorista clan del golfo del lado
colombiano
en los primeros meses del 2023
aproximadamente
166 mil migrantes han cruzado por la
selva del Darién convirtiéndola en uno
de los pasos migratorios más importantes
del continente sin embargo el peligro
que representa el terreno selvático
aumenta las condiciones climáticas
extremas y la presencia de traficantes
de personas hacen del daría en un
infierno para los migrantes 60 decesos
no tengo el número Exacto pero van más
de 60 decesos Yo sé que en estas dos una
semana y media hubieron como 10 10
decesos fue por la inundaciones la alza
de los ríos y muchas personas se
ahogaron según estimaciones del gobierno
de Panamá se espera que aproximadamente
400.000 personas crucen el tapón del
Dari en este año lo que duplicaría el
flujo de personas que pasaron por la
selva en 2022
en otras noticias vamos a Colombia donde
este viernes el presidente Gustavo Petro
retiró del cargo a su jefa de gabinete y
al embajador en Venezuela tras un
escándalo por presuntas interceptaciones
telefónicas ordenadas Contra quién era
la cuidadora del hijo de la funcionaria
y en las que resultó involucrado el
ahora ex embajador en Venezuela marinas
ardiña con los detalles
un robo un polígrafo presuntas escuchas
telefónicas ilegales los escándalos de
la última semana en el seno del
ejecutivo colombiano hacen temblar la
casa de nariño con el retiro de las dos
personas de mayor confianza del
presidente Gustavo Petro Laura Sarabia
su jefa de gabinete en mano derecha y el
embajador de Colombia en Venezuela
Armando Benedetti y funcionaria querida
y estimada y el embajador de Venezuela
se retiran del gobierno para que desde
el poder que implica esos cargos no se
pueda tener ni siquiera la desconfianza
de que se va a alterar los procesos de
investigación que no nos corresponden a
nosotros
le corresponden a las autoridades
competentes por ahí Sarabia de 29 años
sometió al polígrafo a la niñera de su
hijo tras un robo en su casa que la
fiscalía está investigando la misma fue
también empleada de Benedetti quien es
señalado de estar detrás de la denuncia
trabajadora que además habría sido
víctima de escuchas ilegales en un país
donde el mismo Petro fue víctima de las
también conocidas como chuzadas durante
el gobierno del ultraderechista Álvaro
Uribe Pues la verdad que en Colombia
esto has tenido consecuencias tenebrosas
porque organismos de inteligencia
incluso organismos del propio poder
ejecutivo practicaron durante décadas
estos métodos de infiltración de
intersecciones telefónicas pero
consecuencias fatales hace un
instrumento de guerra tanto Benedetti
como Sarabia trabajaron juntos para
llevar a Petro a la presidencia pero ya
en la casa de nariño dicen comenzaron
los choques por cargos en El Ejecutivo
ambos presentaron su renuncias al
mandatario
agradezco su respaldo siempre su lealtad
y su voto de confianza cada día
agradezco presidente Gustavo Petro la
confianza que me brindaste al designarme
una de las más importantes tareas para
tu gobierno restablecer las relaciones
entre Colombia y Venezuela lo logramos
el fiscal general señaló que se tomarán
decisiones judiciales por el caso de las
también conocidas como chuzadas mientras
Pedro intenta salvarse a sí mismo en un
momento en el que su popularidad está en
declive así llegamos al final de esta
emisión de directo América aquí en
France 24 ustedes Les agradecemos su
sintonía los invitamos a continuar con
nosotros que ya llega María Clara calle
con toda la información del continente
americano en aquí América feliz noche
para todos